[Music]
yet lost a general Toronto Farooq
Abdullah for abrini on the invasion
dinelli decided Lucas fresco ha ha
differences enter the presidential
office in tired fabulous person bhava
Jamaica free donuts Mankato pour on dosa
- dietra Gentek donk
Laconia a lasagna chile vassal wakana
prema no salmon exodus from the person
doe in Canton key Bautista too far down
on all seven Rocco
the Quebec City keep Ginetta possibly le
rêve we prefer surrealism a organisation
digital key phenomena Vermont affiliated
curricula Union Jaclyn Alec Des Moines
earth for medieval detective yamakawa
Jeff in agenda needed Ashanti méxico
bottom aha I'll compile again normal
vectors affair at Olympus cure get no
attention take a unique on facility on
the ecology a Saturn from Zambia
Tahoe to dalla sua sponte resolve shake
good care I tested a shack Pierre du
Bois I see a battery a llama a Katya
Lama Tashi a llama piranha keep federal
unfasten magnifique a decline in energy
required local referendum on ah - ah -
ah - ooh kill em ooh ha like a normal
common to be others confess the
government ctrl Jon Stewart banking has
always been an esoteric endeavored
there's never been a great number of
people doing it you have this
transformation of raw material the
alteration of nature and in the end you
get something that just exudes power
[Music]
this is Valyrian steel my father saw the
ancient swords on Game of Thrones forged
with valerian steel were stronger and
lighter than any other weapon no one
knows how they were made in the real
world over a thousand years ago in
Viking lands there was also a series of
special swords with mysterious origins
and a blacksmith in Wisconsin tried to
make one this is an old Bert sword from
about 850 to maybe early 1200s in viking
controlled lands you had a sword that
had a name inlay called bull foot which
roughly translates to a wolf's tooth or
wolf bear it's a word of power there
were only 350 known ulfberht swords
forged with the quality of Steel that
didn't emerge in Europe for another
thousand years no one knows exactly how
they were made I think I've come fairly
close or at least a pretty good
rendition of how they made those blades
steel is a pretty special material we
know a great deal about it and we know
almost nothing about it so with the old
Bert you have a mythical steel mirrored
in the game of thrones where you have
this deal that no one is able to
reproduce that black Valyrian steel
sword making technology still holds a
bit of alchemy a bit of mysticism in it
we want to believe that there's
something that we can't understand
there's still mysteries in steel
I'm a fighter because that's all I've
known how to eat my name is Tanya Smith
and I'm a competitive historical sensor
we train in a system developed by a 14th
century master and practice until the
16th century we built a really awesome
community of women and we're all doing
it together I trained in peach in
longsword it's my primary weapon
I'm size 2 and my longsword comes up to
shoulder level it's empowering and fun
you can use it to cut you could use it
this rust you can get close and range
and grapple and really kick ass with
[Music]
houses were very very small in the
beginning it felt like I was the only
woman and think the token girl it was
something I was comfortable with at
first but as I got better and as I
started developing my goals as a fighter
I realized I wanted to have a community
of other women with shared philosophy
an event I planned was a women's
tournament one of the first of its kind
in the US
[Music]
people will view swimming offense as
lesser but I shouldn't have to be
someone who still my height for double
my weight to prove that I'm a good
fencer
so standard should be beating best
fighters
[Music]
women make good fighters because they
want to be there they put their heart
and souls into it
you don't do this because you're forced
to be there you don't do this because
there's an expectation to be there they
do it because they're passionate about
it
[Music]
Mirek truck is Asano fetch e i'ma holla
see and I so quieres Takashi what those
characters are speaking isn't gibberish
it's actually a language called Dothraki
and it was invented by this guy David
Peterson in lovely Orange County
California David Peterson is what we
call a komlang ER and inventor of
languages coddling is the intentional
creation of a full language creating its
full grammar it's full phonology it's
writing system if it has one and its
entire lexicon david has written many
languages but the first one he wrote was
back in 2000 I was taking an intro
linguistics class at UC Berkeley in 2000
and it was just one day during class I
started scribbling on my notes my very
first language he named it after his
girlfriend made baby an according to
David himself it's irredeemably awful
it's just not not worth it even
considering anymore everything I was
doing with his language was just a kind
of really fancy bizarre way to speak
English so I kind of just started over
and said I write ground zero how do I be
a language creator before we move
forward let's take a quick step back and
talk about the Godfather of modern
combining JRR Tolkien's you probably
know this name because he's the author
of The Hobbit and Lord of the Rings
he created fourteen different languages
for youth within middle-earth Quenya and
Sindarin are probably his most famous he
was the very first person that we know
of to create languages just for fun and
we've been kind of emulating him ever
since now that we've cleared that up we
can move forward
we're here in California because we're
curious about what it takes to create a
successful language David's having two
of his friends who are also con Langer's
come over and speak with us one of them
brought ice cream we were going to do
this outside but it's too hot so we're
going to do it inside the three of them
are talking about how languages are
created and they've come up with five
cent take it away guys
oh hello all right a naturalistic online
needs five basic things one the people
what they do who their neighbors are the
second thing that you're going to need
is a phonology or sound system
do you have voiced and voiceless
consonants do you have aspirated
consonants three words all the nouns all
the burbs all the modifiers fourth
grammar which is the fun part
finally history you know how the
meanings of words changed over time and
you need to know how the grammar of your
language evolved from us time in the
distant past
- what's youth now now that we've got
that settled let's finish this in the
past 15 years somebody who created
language went from somebody who is like
oh you're a nerd - you know oh wow
that's that's really nerdy which now
means cool this prolific youth in
television and films proves that it's
not just a passing fancy
for television the difference between a
created language and some other set prop
is that the maximum level of interaction
and if you were ever has with a
background set or with a Prophet's have
seen it on screen a language on the
other hand when you hear it that's the
that's the most real language ever get
for that reason you have to have a fully
created language for a television show
and not just a bunch of gibberish what's
that good thank god it's punching it's
kicking
armored combat is sort of like MMA but
with weapons to me this is the ultimate
combat sport
my name is Andres Inoue I'm the
co-founder of the armored combat league
I'm the captain of the national sword
fighting team the USA Knight our form of
armored combat started a little over
four years ago it came to our ears that
there were some people over in Europe
that were doing this and we had to build
the United States team and trying to be
competitive for the world most of the
arms and armor that we use comes from
the late 14th early 15th century Western
Europe now there's some other armors but
the best bang for the buck is usually
late 14th century or early 15th century
armor it's kind of counterintuitive but
if you're wearing decent armor and you
get hit with a sword half the time you
don't even know you'd be hit if you play
football you've done a rougher thing
it's a brawl I mean there's no doubt
about it you're going out there and
you're brawling just like in rugby or a
football you've got to have a plan when
you go out there the flankers end up
with three people on them and you end up
with two now melees are a lot more
intense those rules are you fight until
submission or until you put somebody
down to the ground there's no typical
person for armoured combat you've got
people from all walks of life whether
it's some sort of martial arts or
football or rugby there's some history
buffs too and they'll fight and fight
and fight and they'll give everything to
the point of exhaustion that's what
makes a winner
it's all here these guys will go hard at
each other they're going to be swinging
as hard as they can they're trying to
knock you down they're trying to get you
to submit and then they're going to help
you up they're going to pat you on the
back and there's you'll have a steak and
a beer with it
[Music]